[Music]
that's me you all get to see Ricky
Martin and American crime story Versace
but right now get ready to go home I
then so Kelsey states explain yeah Ricky
is opening the doors to his palatial
Beverly Hills past
livin la vida loca more like Ricky's
living the good life
inside this 11,000 square foot
mid-century modern mansion purchase
price 13.5 million dollars and we walked
in here we fell in love with this home
immediately
he shares the seven bedroom eight and a
half bathroom digs with his 9 year old
twins and husband JaJuan yosef plenty of
space for what Ricky promises is a
growing family I want a big family I
come from a big family so yeah maybe two
more I'd say Ricky tells Architectural
Digest that his boys love playing
outside and he's promised them a custom
tree house we don't really hang out how
much but our kids too from here to the
pool they jump inside there's a movie
theater an art studio and a master suite
with a jaw-dropping closet this is a
dream closet I am very happy in this
closet know I usually have an inflatable
mattress and I sleep in here this was
knitted by a fan it's like a blanket and
it's very comfortable kids love it and
fans will recognize these I think we
should totally just talk about your
amazing Grammys well good I would have
them in my office or in my recording
studio but you don't said now let's have
them here
Rickie's currently building a home
recording studio and says his boys are
already showing an interest in the biz
I'm gonna have my recording studio in
there right now it looks like a cave
there's bats that help whatever you can
imagine is it's incredible how they've
grown and they do love music something
very special is happening um can I just
mention it has been almost 20 years
since we met Ricky leave them to vida
loca and I feel like he's aging in
Reverse I mean it must be that house 13
million dollars is a bargain
crazy yeah
[Music]
you